wald es ist ein jahr her dass angela
merkel verkündet hat sie wolle nicht
wieder für den cdu vorsitz kandidieren
auf dem nächsten bundesparteitag der cdu
im dezember in hamburg werde ich nicht
wieder für das amt der vorsitzenden der
cdu deutschlands kandidieren grund genug
also um antwort zu fragen wie war das
eigentlich mit angela merkel und der cdu
wie hat sie die partei geführt wie hat
sich die partei auch genutzt um ihre
politischen ziele durchzusetzen denn
dafür ist ein partei natürlich da aus
der sicht eines kanzlers die politischen
ziele auch nach unten durchzusetzen
zunächst in die eigenen reihen und von
da aus in die wählerschaft ins wahl volk
dabei ist ein vergleich mit ihrem cdu
vorgänger helmut kohl recht hilfreich
kohl hat die cdu ganz anders geführt
kohl ist sozusagen in die partei hinein
geboren der ist als junge in die junge
union gegangen ist in der partei groß
geworden es war eine familie für ihn
familie wie kohl gesagt hätte für merkel
war das ganz anders lieber 34 eine
fertige erwachsene die aus einem anderen
politischen system gekommen ist die sich
auch andere parteien einmal angeguckt
hat dann beschlossen hat sie geht zur
cdu die gesamte familienphase oder
familien bildungs phase die bei ihr
gefehlt
kohl hatte ein dickes telefonbuch kohl
hatte unendlich viele kontakte aus
jahren und jahrzehnten der parteiarbeit
als der kanzler war hat er dieses buch
genutztes war goldwert er hat ständig
mit parteimitgliedern gesprochen mit
ortsvereinsvorsitzenden mit
bezirksvorsitzenden er konnte auch mal
privat mit ihnen reden und so ein anruf
aus dem kanzleramt hatte natürlich ein
enormes gewicht und in seinem telefonat
kann man dann auch die politischen ziele
gut durchsetzen weil dann ja schließlich
diejenigen die sie weiter tragen müssen
die sie an die basis tagen müssen sagen
können
der kanzler hat beim jahren gerufen das
ein einmaliges erfolgserlebnis
natürlich spricht angela merkel auch mit
den gliederungen der partei empfängt sie
im kanzleramt besucht sie geht auf
regionalpartei tage aber nicht annähernd
in dem ausmaß wie cool das getan hat
sie setzt ihre ziele anders durch sie
exekutiert sie mehr exekutive
das steht für regierung die
parteimitglieder sind abends ins bett
gegangen in der festen annahme dass die
atomkraftwerke in deutschland schon
dafür sorgen würden dass es am nächsten
tag wieder hell wird und was müssen sie
dann aus dem radio erfahren die
atomkraftwerke werden abgeschaltet
wer als erklärt niemand im gegenteil
kurz vorher aber noch geschlossen worden
die laufzeiten zu verlängern und in der
flüchtlingskrise ist es im grunde
genommen ähnlich gelaufen angela merkel
hat beschlossen sie für eine asylpolitik
macht wie sie mit den vielen
flüchtlingen aus dem bürgerkriegsland
syrien vor allem umgehen würde
aber sie hat nicht etwa ihrer partei als
sie merkte wie kritisch das aufgenommen
wird und wie wütend ärgerlich und
unzufrieden viele waren gesagt ich habe
verständnis für euch geschweige denn
dass sie zugegeben hätte ihre partei zu
überfordern oder vielleicht einen fehler
zu machen
vielmehr hat sie gesagt wenn wir jetzt
anfangen uns noch entschuldigen zu
müssen dafür dass wir in notsituationen
ein freundliches gesicht zeigen dann ist
das nicht mein land so ein satz wäre
helmut kohl vermutlich nie über die
lippen gekommen hätte er versucht seine
partei von der richtigkeit seines weges
zu überzeugen
jeder kanzler setzt nicht die ziele
durch die er selber hat deren irgendwo
in der bevölkerung vorkommen ein kanzler
kann mit aller macht immer nur das
durchsetzen was tatsächlich auch eine
mehrheitsmeinung ist auch angela merkel
hat nicht etwa die atomkraftwerke
abgeschaltet um es mal kurz zu sagen
gegen den willen der deutschen
bevölkerung sondern
er hat bewusst eine mehrheit will die
atomkraft nicht mehr
und also hat sie entsprechend gehandelt
aber sie hat das nicht wirklich
vermittelt sie hat nicht geworden für
das was sie getan hat vielleicht hätte
auch in der flüchtlingspolitik etwas
mehr werben ja geholfen
es hätte sicherlich nicht dazu geführt
dass die partei die heute gegen angela
merkel zu felde zieht die vor allen
dingen mit dem slogan merkel muss weg
groß geworden ist die afg nämlich dass
diese partei nicht entstanden wäre
aber vielleicht wäre sie nicht ganz so
groß geworden vielleicht hätten sich
doch ein paar cdu-mitglieder noch etwas
wohler in ihrer partei gefühlt und
hätten gesagt ich verstehe schon warum
die vorsitzende die ja auch kanzlerin
ist das gemacht hat aber diese art zu
werben das war helmut kohl was kann
angela merkel nicht so gut aber
natürlich regiert jede oder besser
gesagt geht er macht seine arbeit wie
seine art ist
[Musik]